the first rule finger off the trigger
finger off let's check it yep
figure out the trick finger off the
trigger it's changed my mind time for
this week's edition we not only
revisited the ever relevant topic of gun
control but we decided to mix things up
a little bit by taking the very students
we discussed the matter with to the gun
range to learn the basics of firearm
safety shooting in the process of
actually purchasing a gun one thing
we've learned with the change my mind
conversations most people simply don't
have all the information how would you
define assault rifle like like an
automated weapon that is capable of mass
shootings like I don't think a pistol is
capable of what like an assault rifle
fifteen can do there should definitely
be more like restrictions on how like
you can get one like there are people
out there as you've seen like that
aren't fine that can do the same thing
that I can do you know so like okay so I
don't mean think she's probably unaware
of the process do you think you can just
walk in and buy a gun no you need like a
gun license right no no you don't need a
gun license you need a gun license but
you do need the driver's license a bad
ID and a lot of paperwork and there is a
background check I knew there was like
some restrictions but I don't I didn't
know I knew there was some but I still
believe there should be like more I just
don't know what okay like what if I were
to tell you that half a million to over
three million innocent lives are saved
each year at one simple fact
defensive use of the firearm how many
people have corner of the CDC a minimum
of 500,000 potentially over three
million and by the way that's really
hard to just that doesn't take into
account many times the firearm saves a
life just by brandishing it and the shot
is never fired I always encourage women
if you can to at least go learn how to
shoot and protect yourself responsibly
and then consider purchasing a firearm
do I have you own a firearm no but a
friend whose dad has a law and she has
one too and have you ever shot firearm
I'm never but she yes she neither one of
the times Jonah and Tara yeah okay would
you be willing to maybe in a follow-up
we could do a segment on this go with me
to arrange shoot for the first time and
purchase a purchase a fire okay they
didn't know every about firearm said
that's okay enter the twist on this
week's change my mind where we took
these gals eager and willing to learn
the range for the first time
all right so this is how we're gonna
start so the first thing before I do
anything with you before I do anything
with you is the first rule and we had
our last will see if you do better than
the last came in first I'm just finger
off the trigger so don't be afraid
because you know it's not loaded so hold
it firmly and so the one hand push that
button push that out check it
have her check it and then push your
back yep
just always keep it aim somewhere yep
[Music]
now feel this kind of that's the reason
that figured there's a it's safe but
also kind of pinch it with your thumb
here is you're kind of pushing into your
hand and you're squeezing your fingers
together so that it holds it as stable
as
this is probably the least it's most
people least intimidated gun reform kind
of we talked about there or your school
no one really is even talking about
these yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that seems pretty far doesn't it that's
only seven yards that's where most
attacks most self-defense situations
happen within seven yards seven yards so
to give an idea when people say like
comma of myth we'll go through is like
couldn't you shoot them in the leg or do
you have to shoot them you know to kill
them picture a person at seven yards
that's you know it's actually you'd have
to get it in one in the in that white
circle while the person is moving so who
wants to go first it's already loaded
that's the semi-automatic so same thing
when you're ready just squeeze that
trigger even that Center breathe
stabilize it you know all the time in
the world good
that was just to the to the right on the
red finger off the trigger if you're not
shooting just line it up and just
squeeze that trigger and you should be
fine it's definitely hard to control a
little bit longer trigger but same thing
one shot one yes yeah basically for
self-defense didn't we speaking about
this and this is the revolver equivalent
to the nine-millimeter which is what
we're gonna do next the 9 mil it's the
exact same gun as a 22 a 9-millimeter
platform when people say shooting the
leg no a police officer is gonna use
something significantly more powerful
than that and see how hard it is just to
once you get into a level of
self-defense to control it just it takes
practice which is why typically I don't
know if you know this concealed carry
holders are actually six times less
likely to commit crimes than even
off-duty police officers and that's
because typically we tend to practice a
lot we go through the courses you know
so this is gonna see who's gonna be a
louder but it's actually easier to
control than a handgun so I'll show you
first I'll just take a shot and you know
what AR stands for
no oh and another thought
it stands for Armalite Armalite yeah
it's fully semi-automatic it's just like
y'all the other guns at you okay don't
be shy coming up I'll walk you through
it believe me it's it's not it just
sounds loud because it's a there's a lot
more so finger always off the trigger
haha sorry
that's more sound than kick right I know
there's not that much kick it's easier
to actually hold and shoot than the
handgun it's just loud in here there you
go good alright let's take a break you
have us a break it's really not that
it's just the wait it yeah cuz it's
heavy
there's substantial ease but would you
say it's easier than say even the
revolver as far as controlling it yeah
there's two there's three numbers four
one two three four so this is just
really simply just loading it put it in
underneath take your pardon
this one doesn't you can buy it it's
that's a part of the assault weapons ban
so this is perfectly legal oh it had a
magazine or is it all magazine loading
shotguns or is it just magazine okay
that's a good example as to what's
banned if this is a semi-automatic it
can't have a magazine this is illegal if
it had a magazine no now that were
semi-automatic like the AR it definitely
couldn't be a lot of magazine now it's
just if it's it sometimes sometimes it
entirely depends if it's detachable as a
matter of fact to give you an idea this
same gun would be illegal if the grip
were a pistol grip
that's the assault weapons ban and the
whole purpose of it was it wasn't to
make people safer you want to tell me
that me holding it this way or this way
it's gonna stop a school shooting it was
just to disrupt the firearm
manufacturing industry and make it hard
and you know it's a PR battle so good
once you're ready you're gonna pump it
it's not it's not chambered so you're
gonna pump this back and forward and
then just aim and shoot this one's
pretty simple does have some kick for
sure but just so you've done it once so
really make sure yeah there you go pump
it forward and back finger off the
trigger you okay that's artist one to
shoot back now forward all the way there
you go it is ready get it get it right
in there
that's sorry get right in that okay it's
gonna give you some kicks to hold a firm
grip on it
you okay yes you want to shoot another
one you're good
okay ladies good job but the truth is a
shotgun that's just a 12-gauge shotgun
you've heard most no anymore no one ever
talks about it that's one of the most
common hunting guns but certainly as far
as if you're just talking about the most
damage that's why actually shotguns a
lot of shotguns have been used in public
shootings that they just modify because
that thing is I mean it's hard to
control but it really is I mean that's
lug that you fired would go through
Jarrod mark both of you and the drywall
yeah
where's the ar-15 would not but it just
doesn't look because it's a pump and no
one thinks it because they've grown up
with it and so no one really talks about
it so if the goal is really to make if
we're talking about removing guns that
could damage people that would be that
but no that's not another purpose did it
surprise you at all that of the firearms
the ones that people don't really even
talk about I mentioned like banding and
all is that last shotgun yeah okay
and it makes a much bigger hole
yeah so would you shoot again oh you
would you would you you seem like you
were the most eager to get back up there
after shooting out of my way if if you
were to buy one for yourself what would
you get the 9-millimeter ppq well let
they have that here so let's go through
the purchase yes you guys over 21 can we
still see the profit yes well you know I
can it's still over on the background a
22 platform okay yes but you cannot buy
a handgun I forgot about that even that
was it's been a while since I'm 21
yeah are there any of these that
interest you that you would you like to
get the you sounded like you were keen
on that handgun yep this is wait till
you're 21 if you want to get one of
these you you can but if you like a you
know feel how about we just go through
the background okay let's go okay so
let's let's do it as they're gonna get
that yeah but let's do the background
check yes actually that's kind of
interesting because we were just gonna
go through so you would learn the
process but you can't really go through
the process for the gun that you want to
do what any one be allowed to buy it so
this is the process any firearm that you
purchase that you go through everyone in
the this state legally yes whoever comes
in here has to purchase the firearm for
themselves because they have to pass the
background check there's something
called a straw which should be like you
were to come in here and I get the
feeling that you're buying a gun for her
but you're doing the background check in
your name
go to jail if I sell you together those
things like we've actually had to do
that we tell the gentleman I hear the
conversation I'm like wait who's this
more than they lie to me when they turn
on talked about it right well I'm not
gonna say the gun right this isn't like
a gun registry so like just paperwork we
fell out doesn't go anywhere we put in a
filing cabinet the government doesn't
know who owns what yeah there's more
guns here than our people so it's not
there's no way to track down where this
gun goes after you leave the store with
it some of them they come here and we
say hey didn't they have to know your
name say did this person buy a gun I can
tell you what gun you bought all right
so this is your apartment you filling
out it's called a 4473 and it takes all
your information you got to put energy
exactly as it appears on your license
here capitalized who capitalized it
there's one thing that people mess up is
where it says County they blow through
and they put us a nothing yeah if you
were in another country you would be
able to buy a gun actually so it's
County so make sure you read everything
all this stuff is laws that you need to
know when you buy a gun another one
where felons are you know I don't think
yeah I know what about domestic abuse no
you know slap your boyfriend around no
they wouldn't know I haven't you heard
it's as easy as buying a toothbrush a
firearm I'm honestly scared of the
shotgun oh [ __ ] oh really
no she was very good with the firearms
oh she had really good figure you know
trigger control huh yeah
okay yes so I take all that information
a tattoo a they go on the computer to
FBI and put it in there or I can call
them on the phone just sometimes we have
to do the computer system is all backed
up which it is a lot of the time so
we're gonna find out if you've committed
any crimes right here you sure last
chance to turn back yeah pretty thorough
questionnaire there huh
that surprised you yeah
and he's putting it through the database
right now to the FBI let us know if
you've lied about any of those questions
yeah that's going everything so license
to carry the whole different process so
this is just you legally on that firearm
but you know it's different state to
state so for example Bernie sander state
Vermont you don't need any license to
carry at all but that's it but in Texas
you have to go through a course and it's
basically a full Saturday course they do
a little bit more of a stringent
background check then it takes about six
weeks to three months to get your card a
concealed carry card so that's that's a
different process and you have to be I
believe Molly I have to be 21 to do that
so I need your signature here
and then for two years 2018 and I'm
gonna go back call the FBI I'm just
gonna do it on the computer all this
information in and then usually it's
almost like the same thing that a cop
sees in his trunk you know exactly the
same thing but the same thing goes back
instantly usually so so last chance no
none of these interest you you weren't
you were I say what if you you have
John's info if you were to call John
let's do this we'll go through this link
but if you at your birthday call John
you're like I still want to buy that
Walter will take you back and we'll get
that one yes but two years your 20 I'll
call you okay
you can call me absolutely call John
just barely got a 62% yeah no sorry I'm
taking you ever been in trouble physican
right back she's a good person at this
point we saw you the gun so yeah so you
pass the background check what would you
say about your first experience shooting
after going through the process and
feeling comfortable with it it was fine
especially like the first couple of
shots but I don't think I'd be out
comfortable we didn't go through the
whole life right yeah your demonstration
oh yeah we were both pretty good after a
while you both got the hang of it you
actually both good good first-time
shooters did it surprise you how long
kind of a background check took yeah and
I he like one through last guy and stuff
I know that he do that because there was
one thing you brought up when were you
TD that's a big reason why we wanted to
come here was he talked about sort of
background checks and so well there
already are background checks and that's
kind of that's why there's a disconnect
we're talking about in the conversation
and people anyone who's purchased a
firearm legally when they hear someone a
new say we need background checks
when you talk because you know it goes
your notes every time has your
perspective changed at all kind of like
when we talk about sort of gun control
or common sense gun reform yeah because
there were so many little things about
each gun that could make it like illegal
and not leave a like so fast yeah the
the the basically yeah would be a pistol
grip as opposed to right about you
something that I was like thinking about
from our previous conversation back that
you to be was remember how we're talking
on Mental Illness like how people with
mental illness and that's not being able
to get one what's the line not a good
question yeah
very astute that you asked that question
because suddenly you were thinking since
we last spoke about it when I see that
and I see on television I see
politicians in the talking heads talking
about it for example semi-automatic I'm
normally don't know what that is or they
don't know that there is a background
check
same thing with mental health we feel
good sweeping legislation basically
gives the government power to determine
who's mentally unfit like I take
medication for my anxiety so does that
like what does that mean like does that
mean like you know yeah that's where you
the conversation of rights versus
freedoms are we okay with that or do we
want to give the authority to the
government to say you have a
prescription for anxiety I don't trust
you with a gun and you say yeah but I've
never and they got doesn't matter you
can't have a gun and that's where you up
to decide for yourself you know that's
why I'm Pro secondment because someone
doesn't necessarily know why I need to
carry just like I don't need to know if
you have a prescription for anxiety just
like you don't need to know if she's a
crazy ex-boyfriend who wants to kill her
why she has a gun by her bedside that's
why I err on the side of freedom
especially considering how like you said
you know a lot of people act as though
it's a Wild West to do you think that's
changed where you thought maybe people
were we're just purchasing firearms
really easily once you could once you
commit a felony or anything seriously
violent against them yeah that's when
you forfeit your rights because we want
to sorry you weren't able to purchase a
firearm I didn't know you weren't about
21 but if you make that call in two
years
yes we will get with we will cheat well
there you go thank you so much ladies
appreciate thank you all with a plan
absolutely we appreciate you coming on
out hey if you like this video subscribe
by clicking the button that says
subscribe
if you didn't like this video you should
subscribe anyway because then you can
watch the next video and what you can do
is down vote it and leave a comment
that's really negative you know
particularly if it's something like I
don't know maybe anti somatic even
though I'm not Jewish or something about
my hair or something about my weird nose
just leave a really negative comments
that everyone else around can act like
they care